goo ん
のはーパパ
ん
グレンジャーとはネットの記事が入っていた風船はオレンジと白をかける問われる
おっぱん
まーうんうん
[音楽]
1パーンん
あれあんでなんでなんだなぁちょっと何にゃんは熱湯筆者はるっ回かあっとのに颯一
ござーい
我はねぇはいこんにちはんドクター
始めたら先ほどの事件は失礼したでが今ので完全に分かって柑橘系の果物には共通の
タール成分が含まれている
ビボ年という成分はゴム午後とかせさえ思ってるらしくまあネットでよく動画があると
思うのだが3乾汁をレンズの種類などを風船にかけると爆発して車
風船の表面上に付着したりも年によってゴムが溶け
生まれてします冗談半分で聞いたが
まさか本当だったと驚い道で私は考えてしまって骨盤準備したオレンジ x という
ものが主成分は平静されのレンズの皮から抽出精製したフードグレードオレンジオイル
つまりこれ自分はオレンジなんですつまりこれがあればわざわざみかんの狩猟レンズ
白炭することなく風船を割ることができるそもそもの液体がこの中に入っているからの
霧吹きを準備しましたこの中
にレンズの駅をもっとあっていいでちゃってるなかなかでミカンの汁とかをレンズの
シェルをリーダーに吹きかけることってなさったできないと思うんですよね知るの量的
にも
もうカメラいいか力だというわけでこの申し分ない火力
今回の実験は今からここのタッグさあのプー線を準備します風船を一気に言われる方法
はなかなかないとの中でこの風体ある成分を含んだ決め上のステー出会い分で準備した
風船に来まんべんなくきれいにかければ一瞬で大量の富士山が大爆発を起こす
音樂私は今か
これまでにないくらい風船に曲を覚えることになるだろう
風船あることができていきたいよ非常に全部偶然にきっかけで一斉抱いバックを今日は
をしたいと思いますねえよってはまず手始めに風船をたくさん準備していくと思う
レッツ度イッ
たくれさあここでいっぱいが全店になれば結構の威力になると思うのでできる限り作っ
ていこうと思う
はぁあ
[音楽]
という感じでどんどん膨らませていく
th
[拍手]
裏耳だ java elephant アベ
建てられそうその距離でそれどこの槍で山へ
当事者凄かったからねほんとに移動強く両方敗れた魂ア
完成しましたうん
を持っています
はいというわけでこれでボカーンの準備は整った
先ほど1回実験で試したところを起点が買ってゴムが解ければで少し時差があるんで
瞬間的に爆発することはないと思われますただ
確実に爆発するそれではさっそく全ての店に行きたいをかけていきます
色はビッグバン
[音楽]
トゥ1
ええええええ
[音楽]
はい全部変わりましたーーー
まって本当に怖いやばいもう耳かけてみます
[音楽]
うんあれさっきの軌跡やそんなことはなれたら爆発します時間差です
ん
[音楽]
なんでなんでさっき爆発したよねでも
パッド付バンバンバンバンバンバン
中っていう仲間がすぐだわかっただれだけで
[音楽]
いいした
作成思ったーー
ああああああああああああ
voodoo は
ん
[拍手]
[音楽]
くれません
ブーブー一瞬ヌー
だよねー偶然が減ってきたのでちょっとこっち寄せます
寄せているときに来るの一枚だからそんなにネイバーさんはー
うんこの p で汗の量がすごくないよこれをます ia
わーわーワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンでさぁ
なぜば学舎今さーん
だーっ
さあ混戦
おめ話が次へじゃねーかよ
これがネットで見た時はよ
お前だねがオレンジの汁かけたら一瞬で終われるかもみたいなこと書いてあったからさ
こんだけたくさん準備してた女がオレンジをするっぽい術をつけてさ
あああ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ